une autre journée commence dans la toute
nouvelle vie de michel boudrias une vie
qui n'était pas vraiment prévu mais
qu'il apprivoise tranquillement nouvelle
recrue du bloc québécois il ne m'aime
pas encore de bureau
il a le loisir de passer du temps dans
son comté à terrebonne et l'amicale des
vétérans fait partie des incontournables
son grand oncle on est un des fondateurs
ici avant d'être député michel boudrias
sera toujours un capitaine ex officier
d'infanterie au sein du royal 22e
régiment
il a été déployé en 2010 en afghanistan
une expérience qu'il a changé et c'est
son sens du devoir qui l'a amené à se
lancer en politique l'automne dernier au
grand étonnement de ses frères dans nos
prix pourquoi parce qu'on se disait un
seul 2 qui se présente comme
indépendantiste pour nous le stockons
reste surprenant pour le moins qu'on
puisse dire
mais me chalié tu adores à penser qu'il
va faire un bon travail soit par exemple
c'est pour ces vétérans à voir un des
leurs élus
peu importe ses couleurs et est inespéré
l'amicale c'est bien plus qu'un clip
social depuis 1948 et ici on s'entraîne
moralement et financièrement
aujourd'hui leurs attentes sont immenses
leur capitaine sera leur voix ou
parlement qu'on écoute libre et vétérans
qu'on soit capable il est l'un des seuls
on connaît même pas problème
ils sont jamais consultés pourtant au
delà des histoires de guerre qui ne se
lasse jamais de se raconter
il y a tellement de souffrances et
d'isolement dans la pièce femme de
militaire
micheline laliberté se consacre la
nouvelle génération de vétérans qui
rentrent du front perdu et traumatisé
on peut pas s'attendre à ce qu'il soit
parfaitement normaux mais c'est pas des
malades mentaux non plus et des hommes
ordinaires qui ont un câble qui ont vécu
des choses on se souvient jam ex de ceux
qui sont revenus
on y pense même pas le militaire devenu
politicien écoute et qu'on prend on
entend des cris de détresse on entend
des frustrations on en perd aussi les
cris du coeur comme parlementaire je
veux être le porteur de ballon il ne
sera pas le seul
l'armée a rarement eu autant de poids au
sein du gouvernement
le nouveau ministre de la défense arrive
lui aussi du franc à 44 ans il est
décoré les plus hautes distinctions de
l'armée il ne compte plus le nombre de
fois où il a risqué sa vie
le lieutenant colonel a joué un rôle clé
dans l'opération mais 12 à l'une des
plus musclés de la guerre en afghanistan
tout au long de sa carrière il vu la
douleur de ceux qui rentrent à la maison
l'impact sur leurs familles et c'est
pourquoi le ministre vient tout juste de
redonner à l'armée de faire de la
prévention du suicide
une priorité à la lumière d'un rapport
inquiétant sur la santé mentale des
soldats à la voix du ministre s'ajoute
celle du nouveau député libéral inde où
l'asie
il est lancé commandant de l'état-major
de l'armée de terre et il se bat
publiquement pour de meilleures pensions
et de meilleurs soins ça augure bien
je pense que dans le parlement si tout
le monde particulièrement les militaires
l'accès qui siège présentement on cette
ouverture là on peut concourir
un beau programme un beau projet commun
au delà de la partisanerie
en politique comme à la guerre c'est le
courage de ses convictions et la
persévérance qui compte
le courageux que d'aller au front je
t'avais près pareil parce qu'il voyait
lui offrant croyez moi
oui ça de bâton qu'il faut d'avoir un
député qui connaît justement les
problèmes d'accès sont conçus celui
michel boudrias espère aussi prouver que
malgré tous les obstacles
il ya une vie après l'armée doit pas
décider
fidèle à sa grande famille militaire le
capitaine se dirige cette fois vers
ottawa